hello and welcome to the Friday review
of games as always I'm your host Ian
knee Lewis and with me today is our
special guest Steven Spielberg thank you
very much dan dan galpin here as always
to help out with playing the games
basically here online and giving you
guys a lot of great feedback thanks a
lot as always for nominating the games
to our moderator and today we are going
to be doing driving games with
absolutely driving games which actually
are some of my favorite games but I had
never really played them on Android i
played for its the entire for its a
series on my xbox actually started out
with the project gotham racing actually
gets american project gotham racing 3
fixed their their sound well fix the
xbox so we can play their zone exactly
so love these games lots of great titles
but before we get started wanted to make
some special mention today in the studio
with us we have our new engineer
engineer dan meaning other dan dan fam
and producer reto Meier so can you
introduce yourselves guys hey guys is a
this is Daniel Pham just want to say hi
and uh this is a writer and you may know
me better from the android app clinic
which is all immediately before and i'll
be keeping an eye on all of the live
streams and hopefully uh passing any
questions you have straight onto the
guys behind the desk absolutely now
let's see the producer cam that was the
idea i think was just the furniture
getting producer gam all right we got
the producer game guys we'd hang out Oh
me Louis ah there we are yep second from
the top there you go no no I won oh no
we're getting good though absolutely
awesome nothing on it either but uh oh
yeah yeah okay one more one more step
there we go alright hey all right
excellent yes everybody's complaining
this said why don't you
hire a professional and we did so you
can just stop complaining now now on the
show is gonna great that's right okay so
what do we do on the last I think I
really like that all right so well as
far as sucking westco's why don't we go
ahead and open up some some liquid humor
wow this is so yeah well you know it is
a double chocolate stout so today we're
drinking irondale double chocolate stout
from I have no idea actually George
enris apparently at bruneian bottle by
armitage brewing company in san jose so
there we are beautiful so this is local
yeah that's fantabulous gal able that's
all like I don't know English year or
something absolutely babe well well well
exactly there we are there you go
excellent thank you sir although
apparently we are limited in the amount
of time we can show what we're drinking
because after a few number of seconds
the man considers it a beer commercial
yeah I still want to be the man is well
in this case the man is our boss Billy
hi Billy hi Billy mmm so I let's go
ahead and talk about some games what you
want to look at first down all right
well if that two games queued up here
we're actually trying a little bit of a
different tack this time we have we have
to transform of primes rather than one
and the first game I want to look at was
real racing absolutely whoa whoa you're
I mean you really you're gonna make it
hard for anybody all of this huh I know
I know this game is is awesome I
Newlands let's go ahead and take a look
at it okay let's do one dis new career
I'm gonna do easy all right are you sure
you want to be easy yes all right Road
sports let's bring out let's bring up
the camera on that so here we are with
real racing and start off with our club
division this is exactly how you begin
the game and Real Racing is from farming
studios down in Australia and and they
really have I think set the bar for
realistic graphics on a racing game
right
camera two and all right we hit the HOME
key nice yes well let's see how they
recover from that exactly it's our first
test at right exactly where it's
possible that it died hopefully Oh God
God fingers crossed that's what's great
about doing a live program oh man all
right the first thing checking their
license every single time you run yeah
oh you might not like that and the main
reason is because you might be somewhere
where you can't get network connectivity
so have a license policy that lets you
check license intermittently you don't
get it if you don't get contact with the
license server for a couple times it's
not a big deal most most people aren't
going to be able to contact the license
server every single time they play yeah
the server manager policy that we have
built into you know the license server
zacks the way to go it you know we
actually you know think that it makes a
lot of sense of the people can still you
know get their license and yet play the
game on a plane or something like that
idols let's try a quick race instead
let's see how we do sure no easy on the
camera to there hotshot make that so um
and now we're at the exciting loading
screen again I love this loading screen
man it but look at this it's cool I mean
obviously you know you're always going
to have constraints with a mobile device
mobile devices have power and heat and
battery and size constraints that a full
console or desktop computer don't have
but with all that considered it's a
really nice-looking game I mean they've
done all of the interstitials and the
HUD and everything just like I remember
it on my xbox it's great stuff and you
can actually one thing that that's not
easy to figure out if you can actually
change the view here you'll notice we
actually could just but you know you
actually would think that that you would
get a higher framerate when the full hut
was up but actually you don't and I show
that Hut again so here's here's our
different views here's our full screen
there's our front and there's there's
with the HUD right and what's the
problem here down why why
and the theory that I have and again I
have I haven't I've been thrown this one
through all of my tools is that in fact
if you notice the out the border of the
HUD actually has some transom
translucency on it you can see the
outside of those windows and so my
theory is that they're actually drawing
this HUD last in order to get that a
little bit of transparency and what they
probably should be doing is drawing just
the translucent parts of the HUD last
and actually drawing the rest of the HUD
first cuz you'll actually see the
framerate is just killer when it's not
there right they probably can't see it
because I don't think we can capture
video for youtube yeah highest frame
rate this device can put out but take it
big dan's word for it because dan has
sort of a fifth sense when it comes to
frame rate ya know it looks it looks
amazing and actually I I found that I
really love playing it this way I
actually get a sense of speed playing it
full screen without the HUD that's a
nice texture down there yes beautiful
you can even see on the road what I love
is that they're they're using a
beautiful job with filtering there and
you can see MIT mapping though that
textures and beautifully MIT map so that
when it's closed it does not look blurry
and when it's far away it is not you
know clogging down the GPU with lots of
extra drawing and so you know i mean
this this really is just kind of a boy
learn how to put the game even when you
see these buildings that we pass by the
textures might be a slightly bit
blurrier but there but where we have
such a great feeling of speed and the
frame rate is high enough that we don't
even notice it and even little things
like the effects of the the Sun flaring
on the windshield I mean it's it's just
it's just beautifully beautifully done
and you can do the other optimizations
or changes you can make a pretty simple
you can turn on and off the HUD if you
want it have just just be that much more
immersive now it's interesting this game
actually does not have a back button on
the screen which is awesome you actually
have to hit the back key to get here and
then you can actually go and change in
the settings to go and say that I don't
want to have the heads up display and
and now we can actually go back and it's
again it's all driven using the standard
Android navigation system which is cool
and so now there we have it we're really
just full screen which is kind of
awesome like just being able to get to
this view I think is super
killer the other thing is that they
don't have an accelerator all we can do
is break we break by tapping the screen
and so it is no you can't actually put
it into a mode where you need to both
accelerate add break um which can be
nice actually I prefer it that way
because i like to slide around corners I
just decelerating a bit um but I think
they've they made the right choice as
far as making it easy to jump in and
play yes there's a lot of assists on
which is why Dan's is doing so well yes
I'm she's actually why don't you play
this game with the assist soft show them
what it what it feels like okay I just
don't go into your settings and okay
let's go back into settings done and to
wonder under your settings yeah so I
think I have I can't change career
difficulty here I'd have to restore
you'd have to restart the race yeah
exactly so that's that was that was what
I was afraid of but but yeah the game
really just have have a great sliding
scale but if you want to just jump into
it it's great to it there's nothing to
prevent to it again is you're looking at
this freeze frame you can just see how
high quality that that text set road
texture is now let me take a look at
that actually so this is um like you
really I ya see that wouldn't be right
there and the what's really amazing is
is that they've actually done a good job
of simulating a nice oh yeah I don't
think they're actually doing in i select
I don't think that's hard work and do it
mm-hmm at that level but yeah you know
you'll um for a lot of min map stuff so
you'll actually see sort of a line um
you know about let's say an inch from
the bottom of this screen you'd actually
see it turn really blurry or get some
you know just visual artifacts in
general there the attention to detail is
awesome on this game so yeah so this
game also was originally released as
essentially a free demo that was at that
was unlockable and this version is now
the premium version and and it's it's
totally worth it for ninety-nine cents
it's an absolute steal and you know I if
you like racing this game this game
really does get have the best visceral
feel I think of any racing game yeah so
really i think the only thing we're
saying about it is you know if you're
going to paste a big-ass hut on your on
your screen first so that
these parts can z reject pretty fast
mm-hmm and there are no mobile chips
that are really good at overdraw no Jeep
no Android GPU is going to be happy with
tons and tons of over-aggressive just
don't do it the one thing that I'm
missing in this game and it's actually
in every game that we've looked at I'm
really missing good damage yeah I don't
and I don't see why not i think that the
hardware is perfectly capable of running
a damage model even simple one i'm
actually because nobody has it
especially the two gameloft games I'm
looking I'm I'm actually wondering if
they can get the life here well that's
what I was running to this you have to
get a special damage license so that
that is we have the real cars in this
game are beautifully rendered its again
it is it is it is the real car gate the
real car racing game on android yeah but
it is tough it is tough especially
you're not an easy mode but it is nicely
easy that people who just one drive yes
which over yeah as a contrast yeah the
this one I would call this next one uh
423 meets mario kart haha so we're now
looking at asphalt 7 let's let's Anna
and I switch the tablet so we can make a
very very very fast which these are big
big games and some what I'm gonna Ian
play on this one okay you're gonna cue
up the next one yeah I'm gonna write you
up the next one so for this one the game
mechanics are similar in a lot of ways
and since you know we're it's another
one of these games where you start with
a little bit of money and that's gonna
let you buy a car and then you're gonna
compete in races for more cars and more
very i always like this which we switch
now are now we're really on asphalt 7
heat nice all right so yeah and and this
is using a is what is not a free title
this is a pay title but it's a 99-cent
title as well and and it's and it's go
in it is very playable without
additional purchases but it does it does
strongly encourage you to spend
additional money all you're going to go
in a lot to get more stars mom and in
fact you're gonna pay a lot to get more
stars too so i noticed for instance um
the so the first thing you get which is
your
your little tiny fiat abarth i guess i
don't know i don't actually know how to
say that but this is like the entry
level car for every racing game ever um
you want to go up a level right to a
range rover or even just a mini cooper s
that's going to cost you 30 stars that
30 stars is like 10 or 15 bucks actually
in there is it really wow it's quite a
lot let's see get more stars um I guess
yeah yeah there you go to bed but yeah
um or you get one or two stars per race
hmm I so you can see you're going to
grind a lot in this game yeah I mean
these are not cheap so but but you know
aside from that it's actually really fun
the the races themselves are a good time
I'm gonna go in and and to be honest I
kind of i know'd is long if you can
grind in the game I think it's actually
kind of fun it does give it sort of an
RPG element and i think that's that's
actually kind of a you're not entirely a
bad thing yeah in terms of this and
you've got this this interesting thing
where a so i can pay five thousand
dollars for a sponsor which is a little
bit about sponsoring i pay you i know
but ok fine um they've got some goals
here they've got a they've got a little
bit on a style system like project
gotham used to have where you'll get
you'll get some extra points for doing
things like drifting and getting air hmm
and they also have some really beautiful
interstitials they actually do now yeah
it's it's very professional i mean it's
you know it's exactly the kind of thing
you'd expect now once again this is a
very simple game i think it is an auto
accelerator you have to if you want a
break you have to get the screen but
they have a nitro bonus system because
you of course ad right yes um which is
that's the mario kart element and
actually just to point out there are
many many control schemes for asphalt 7
so you get you cannot you can use tap on
the screen you can use virtual wheel
there's just tons and tons of different
ways you can still but i'll tell you you
know with especially with the newer
android tablets having a significant
improvement in whoa nice Eric Lee
improved their gyroscopes and
accelerometers so you can get you get
the attitude sensor to work really
really well now now I'll take a couple
things about this game 1 of this game
actually has shortcuts in the races
which I which are totally fun there's a
lot yeah fine there's far more than just
one route through any of the individual
races my only complaints about this game
are really that at you'll see that that
if you look at the quality of if you
have to pause key actors we can take a
look at one of these frames I can't
actually go to frame my dad you pause I
guess you can't I thought you could
anyways which we go no no no you can't
you can't just you can't just pause yeah
anyway so well if you can see though if
you look down the quality of the road
just it's not anywhere near what real
racing is putting out and actually you
look at the vegetation going by you can
see that the stuff that's near the
camera is really really pixelated right
but you never noticed that because I
going too damn fast exactly also from a
frame rate perspective it is not we're
not we're not getting you know
consistently high frame rates it's
pretty good I mean this is definitely
but I think that it doesn't bother me
and actually if you if you play it on
like I played on the Nexus 7 um I never
noticed a primary problem at all yeah I
don't have your supernatural skill
judging frame rates so it is interesting
so this one I did actually throw into
Purefoy to take a look at it and I was
actually going to do sort of interactive
/ HUD you on the show today but I think
they'd know but Dan chickened out I did
I chickened out but but partially
because it wasn't interesting enough
with this sort of this sort of game but
I one thing it is interesting is you'll
on this game you'll notice the cars are
drawn last and so so we are just which
is a little unfortunate cuz it just
taking up a large chunk of the screen
you know for the players car yeah yes
you'd probably want to draw the other
things last as well of course this is
this is something that is just oh yeah
check out
own so adrenaline mode is like your
intron mode yeah no wrong it's awesome I
have no idea how I even got there but Oh
Rach I see that's my problem right I
just wrecked my car is completely
smashed up but it looks perfect why why
did fiat make you do that it's very
possible so the yeah in general what you
want to do is draw your foreground
elements first so that you can take
advantage of hierarchical Z and in this
case what you probably want to do you
know for a racing game is you can assume
that the players car is always going to
be in the foreground anything else is
probably not worth it the other cars are
almost never on the foreground yeah I
mean you really see when you see the
vegetation on the left-hand side of the
screen that we're going on that that's
where you really really see the the
quality I think that's at exel density
issue it is you know they just aren't
loading up big enough textures um
although you know they have a lot of
varied textures they don't for the for
the areas of the track that are further
away it's actually very well done yes
absolutely absolutely I just I just
think there's there's probably one level
of MIT mapping that's missing right and
but you know that I know in the game
development process I wouldn't be
surprised if that level was created and
then thrown away very very possible you
can also say there is a bit of pop up
going on you look at I just noticed some
pop up and that's an issue especially
it's actually a little bit surprising
considering for instance this particular
GPU is really excellent at geometry yes
compared to its pixel performance suit
you actually probably get more out of
pushing your far z plane out a little
bit yeah well you know it's not going to
be the right choice for every Y and also
they don't only really is good if you
are not if you're drawing in in the
reverse draw order you know if you're if
you're drawing in order you're going to
you're going by pushing your Z plane out
you're still going to have some pretty
big performance problems if you're well
if you're going back to front yeah
you're going right if your bunny should
never do right exactly only you know
drawing your stuff um back to front is
always the wrong choice unless you have
to do alpha what you should be doing is
you know just like these guys hear you
you should be drawing that alpha area
laughs absolutely so that's that's it's
basically a you know something that
everyone needs to look at that being
said you know this game is totally fun
and and that's and that's and and it is
beautiful looking to kick I just want to
see it that much better like that I
really do too and and I would love to
see more you know some more collisions
more particles my guess is that the very
top end of Android devices especially
tablet could handle more than what we're
seeing here I would love I would pay
extra to get let's say a Tegra optimized
version of this or a tablet optimized
version of this into to play around with
because I think this game could be even
cooler than it is totally totally and
you know just uh you know interesting
enough you know hitting the back key a
multiple times just gets it out gets us
out to the menu kind of the way we'd
like you know they've done a good job of
me out navigation is great and and
Boomer we're back out so so that's that
let me see if I now I was going to try
to cue up the next game on this on this
tablet and I will see whether I actually
managed to successfully do that before
we start the next game I think producer
retail has something Oh exactly see he
is on the screen so so it's a couple of
comments on YouTube than on the G+
stream hmm so leaf points out that
asphalt 7 does notification spam after
not playing it for a few days oh how
many people don't do notification spam
now the real question on this actually
is whether or not you can you can
actually turn off notifications and by
the way but gameloft assures me that if
the game the game is actually intended
to be playable offline if for some
reason it is this there's you saw that
network error has occurred we try cancel
they say that's if that's actually a bug
so what we're asking people to do now is
we understand that some people like
notifications we don't know who those
people are but apparently some people do
like notifications um what we want to do
is make sure that users who don't want
notifications or even users who do want
notifications they don't want all of
them have the ability to control that
now of course we added new features to
jellybean to make it easier to control
the kinds of Notre
you get from different apps that's sort
of an all-or-nothing thing you can say
this Adam never allowed to send me
notifications or this app is allowed now
me personally I don't mind being told
for instance there is a massive sale on
some in-app item of a game I like but I
do hate personally I am if you hate
those notifications that are like you
played me in a while when you come back
I mean yeah you know if I wanted
somebody whining at me about coming to
play I'd play GTA four ya know exactly
and actually one of the things I was
looking for and I didn't actually check
this game before we started and I was
looking to see if there was a way to
disable that within the game doesn't
look like there is you know we we
strongly encourage developers to make
that something they can turn off and
because a lot of users prefer it now it
went on one of the other gameloft games
if you turn off notifications every
single time you start off the guy start
up the game at pop with a dialogue and
hey you realize you've turned off
notifications would you like to spend
them on itunes bad hey i noticed I'm not
your default game player for this
machine would you like to change that
come on so there will come a day when I
a those people will be the first up
against the wall but even before that
there will come a day when that is no
longer considered feature worthy yeah we
really want we really want to make sure
the user experience is you know and and
addressing the user concerns are the
number one number one priority for
developers and you know we understand
the notifications are useful there's a
lot of game players who actually really
like them you know and certainly on a
lot of the games or resource management
is an issue or their daily bonuses you
know that's really awesome you know like
you know playing playing dungeon hunter
knowing hey man there's there's like if
I play today I'm I have an opportunity
to get 5,000 gold for doing this that's
kind of cool as long as I can turn it
off right and so let's we do have the
other games you wanted we want to go on
with other other questions one more
question is this one more so this is an
actual question programming question
from Alex ok on G+ dream and he says you
guys always pay say to pay attention to
the resolution of the art assets within
games so they don't look blurry or
overstretched I'd like to know what you
think about pixel art style of graphics
do you think it's ok to do all the art
on a canvas of say 400 x 240 height
with pixel art style he's asking because
the pixel art looks nice when stretch
but it's all messed up when shrunken and
that goes against standard best
practices on game art where you
obviously you know have high res assets
and then shrink them down although
making two separate groups of artwork
both big and small seems to be a better
option it's not practical because it's
going to take too many resources well
remember that the reason it looks bad
when when its trunk is because we're
doing the scaling very quickly and it's
it's usually you know like for instance
OpenGL just implements a bilinear
filtering which isn't very good now if
you run your art through something like
Photoshop and it does al & co's filter
on it you're going to get art that looks
pretty much great yeah exactly i
wouldn't i wouldn't worry too much about
that you also you actually can't
actually you if you go into bitmap
factor you can set the options for
higher quality scaling as well within
your within the actual you know scaling
of the bitmaps and that that may help
you out as well but the truth is yeah I
know my feeling is high high resolution
pixel art looks amazing and and you know
the games we saw have you looked at the
last week's show we were doing tower
defense games we saw some amazing high
res pixel art that just that was looked
mind lonely good on on these devices and
actually scaled down reasonably well and
it's you know I so I think it comes down
to art design and style there definitely
are you know outline pixel art really
doesn't scale very well you know if you
if you're trying to have lots and lots
of really delicate line details those
are going to get lost a lot of time you
do that but it well and you know who
does actually very careful line drawing
Rovio mhm and so they actually put a lot
of effort into making sure that at every
single resolution the black outline
about around the birds is exactly one
pixel wide yeah and they're they're very
very good about that and you know it and
so I think I think it's certainly
possible it more it's more of an art
design question I think than a technical
question when it comes to when it comes
to that I think a lot of people will do
something in pixel art thinking that
that's actually gonna be easier and it's
not doing pixel art well and making it
look great on a modern device and also
appealing to modern users is actually
really tough because you want it to be
old school but you don't actually want
it to be old school you want it to be
evocative rather than representative of
your limitations absolutely but yeah I
mean we certainly love pixel art we've
we've given you no major thumbs up to a
lot of pixel art titles in terms of in
terms of you know what we did the
presentation and I think the real key
thing is just again like anything else
it all depends on the quality of your
artist more as much as much as anything
else under design and no producer rato I
have to ask I was so is that HP c2000
guy on them on the live chat I haven't
seen any questions from him yet okay
yeah he was going to ask a question
about OpenGL i told him i'd answer it
but i'm not gonna answer it if he's not
watching just come on exactly keep an
eye out i will let you know if he is
good let's go ahead and move on to our
next game alright so our next game isn't
really a driving game it would be is
there driving in this game but there is
dryers a lot of drugs isn't really a
racing game i should say it does is it
is a driving game racing we said driving
did we at the yes okay and the only
thing that we put off limits was golf as
i recall that is true we said that it
was not that kind of driving so here we
are it is GTA they've done a great job
of bringing it to android it controls
very very well i actually really like
the fact that the default set of
controls is actually tapping the screen
and rather than accelerometer i think it
works really well for the kind of Arkady
style of driving that is in the game and
so you know since it is driving game
we're going to hit the car now there are
a lot of on-screen buttons in this game
and I would say a lot of that is because
it was you know wasn't really designed
for this kind of system I think if you
were designing it today you would not
have nearly as many button actions as
this game has this is definitely more of
a port than a remix you know I think
it's not it's not really why am i
driving badly yeah it's not really
reimagined for tablet it's just totally
ported so you know what this place
awesomely with is like at IKOS
controller or an xbox 360 controller
yeah if you have into the u.s. all right
it's great they support that if you if
you're on an Android 3x device or on
something like the Xperia Play three
extra higher device
they you know they really do a great job
of making sure those are there for you
guys but other they doubt they've done a
very good job of porting me the game in
the graphics ever know where i played
this was I I met with the wikipad guys
oh yeah you might have seen wikipad
online they were DC and they they handed
me a prototype I and it was playing GTA
3 and I'm like wow it's a it's
completely new experience to be able to
play that on tablet with a with a
controller that's built in oh I'm hoping
that we see more of those and there's
there's several people we keypad Niko's
there's one other they can't remember
yeah moga is also doing it yeah as God
has got a pretty cool controller and
Andres we support USB controllers
basically any USB controller the Linux
support yeah and Bluetooth as well USB
and Bluetooth controller so you know
there's there's a digitally going to be
a lot of choice out there let's run into
a few more trees here in Grand Theft
Auto I'll you know so what what more to
say about this other than it support
then well I know I would love to see a
more native version designed for touch
controls I think that you could go take
it really really far but but they've
done about as good a job as you think
you'd expect to do given where they
started with the you know fairly
complicated joystick interface nice my
cars on fire and I'm in the first omen
training mission um um it's a it's a fun
game what more to say yeah exactly it's
let's not waste any more time they did a
good job oh but there is actually one
thing that's unique about this game if
they still have it they still have the
persistent notification um yes they do
something kind of think Jesus I'm kind
of wacky with that so if you if we go to
the home screen you'll see that it
actually lets you know whether it's
still running and allows you to get back
to the to the game right away I don't
know how how exactly i feel about this
because things do run in the background
and that's like expectation i am so torn
about this because on the one hand it
violates a lot of the philosophy that we
have around android on the other hand
it's done for such a good reason because
basically everything that we've done
around android is for a completely
different use case yes and the use case
of having something that is really
really big and
really really expensive to initialize
but also something that you might want
to interrupt every now and then to let's
say get a phone call hmm is it stuff so
they've they've done something
interesting they basically say okay you
know what we're gonna run all the time
but I instead of just doing that which
is horrible yeah they put up a
persistent notification that says
essentially for our process is still in
memory yeah GTA 3 is sitting here taking
up resources and draining your battery
so that you can go back with fast it is
it is it to stop that yeah it is
actually not draining your battery but
it is to it is still resident in memory
so it doesn't actually keep the game
right the threads are our threads are
stopped but it will it will end up
making things harder for you uh you know
there will be more swapping out yeah I
mean I mean ultimate ultimate Lee
Android will that will kill the process
if you try to run too much stuff I mean
we should actually just try that let's
let's try to launch real racing and see
what happens yeah now I'm a you know
testing fate here you know we're
obviously running to enormous enormous
titles what should happen is we should
actually see GTA get kicked out of
memory always going to do these things
live exactly but my point is that you're
right that it's not consuming CPU but it
is going to consume the battery because
what's going to happen is that smaller
apps are gonna cycle in and out faster
yes yeah I you know and everything is
what once it gets kicked out it should
just be kicked out that's you know
that's it doesn't get kicked back in
unless they're actually running a
service and hopefully though an are
renewing this and they've got a
persistent notifications with it's it's
really hard to tell yeah i actually have
enough to go out of here and then go
back into GTA and yeah well you see the
notification is still there so well
that's true but that doesn't really mean
anything cuz all that me as their
service is still alive it doesn't
necessarily mean their main process yeah
that's looks like let's take a look at
what happens you boom where we are so we
all you know we add that this test I was
a lot of RAM if it's so and and you know
so anyway so you know again you it is
possible to switch to swap between two
rather large games I don't think I want
to push push it and actually swap
between more than that but there we are
with with real racing as well so awesome
nice multitasking going on there a
couple of couple of quick points
from YouTube crispy Corps wants to know
if you can try and see if the two
controls work while driving yes that
just a couple of minutes ago so I'm
guessing that's for GTA there tilt
controls for GTA games there seems to be
a lot of problems with that I think so I
think that then there may be an issue
and as I recall the this is one of those
games that actually has I think
accelerometer issues let's take a look
so let's turn accelerometer on and let's
use tick analog data looks during you
yeah I use analog steering for that on
okay okay and let's take a look as I
recall this this may have been one of
those games that that actually does not
correctly look at the default
orientation when interpreting the
accelerometer but I think as I recall
and it's been it's been a while I think
they do it correctly for tablets and
they may not do it correctly for they
may actually be sensing the type of
device instead of so what will happen is
the orientation is always done with
respect to a default orientation of the
device you know in other words which we
can orientation the home screen expects
to display in and that's not always what
the game expects ironically this isn't
very difficult to deal with where people
get into trouble is when they try to
figure out what a default orientation is
hmm I and then figure out what the
accelerometer is telling them rather
than just believing the quaternion that
they can get from the accelerometer yeah
the quaternion is is is actually always
going to be correct and that's that
that's that's really the key here but
anyways you know the tilt is working
fine here we should try it on a phone
device and see whether it's also
handling that correctly this is I
shouldn't say phone what I should say is
a portrait default device now the
question is are the real question is
what happens on nexus 7 here and so we
can we can tweak it we can i think i
have it on this guy well give that up
and see if there's another question well
dad's getting that going at hpc 2000 is
in fact year so but he would love to
hear the answer to his question yeah
right my question was about how
oh boo whoa look at that I i downloaded
all these files last night at least I
thought I did maybe I do HBC two
thousand asked how easy is it to take a
an OpenGL ES game that's made for some
other system he named a system I
something I hadn't heard of it yeah but
you know whatever you use what you want
if you want a port from another system
that's an interesting question mmm I'll
tell the truth it's it's something that
I think we have mixed feelings about and
when I say we I mean the Android
organization in general we want people
to bring all of the best content on
Android at the same time we don't want
to just see random crummy ports we want
to see things that are built for Android
and for its unique abilities so that
said it's not very difficult to port an
OpenGL ES game that's written in C to
Android there are some issues a lot of
people think that since android is linux
it should be very easy to port any piece
of linux software and that's not
entirely true because android like all
other linux systems is built out of a
lot of different components and there's
some things you can pick and choose in
terms of the libraries and tool chains
we have a specific c runtime that we use
called bionic that a lot of other people
don't use and all of this adds up to
more hassle now normally for a Linux
system this isn't a hassle because you
use something like a PT or you know
macports or one of these things that
compiles everything and runs through a
bunch of compatibility scripts and if
you've ever use a court system you know
that there's like a million different
tests the to figure out where you see
runtime lives and where pilot lives and
all these other things and requests
doesn't do that we distribute binaries
to the phone so or to the device so you
are not able to count on all of the
things that your desktop linux system
has or even all of the things that are
on in the android open source project
right now what we do instead is we
release something called the NDK the
native development kit and that is
there's a lot of things in the NDK but
the real core of it the irreplaceable
piece of it is a set of headers that
form a contract that Google has decided
we will always forget it has it hasn't
it has an 8 in na bi an application
binary interface and the key thing about
that is it for your opengl calls those
opengl calls will be essentially
identical because opengl is a standard
it actually provides a contracted ABI
itself and we're adhering to that
contract so from from an opengl
perspective all the code should pour
over incredibly easily you know
obviously and you know if you're taking
advantage of any architecture specific
implementation details you know
especially extensions those will have to
be looked at but the vast majority
OpenGL code will run absolutely
identically on both platforms well you
will need to be aware one thing though
yes is that because Android is an open
system with a huge number of OEMs I you
can't make as many assumptions about the
GPU hardware as you can with some other
systems absolutely even though the
OpenGL ES ABI is standard and some of
the extensions that you may have come to
rely on or possibly some of the
behaviors or even bugs that you may rely
on on one system are not necessarily
going to be the same on other systems a
good example of that is that PVR GPUs do
geometry sorting and they so they're
almost completely incentive insensitive
to the way you submit geometry but they
are very sensitive to how many state
transitions you do yes whereas Tegra
GPUs are almost exactly the opposite
that change state very fast but you want
to always sort front to back exactly and
so to the real the real keeping and
that's certainly adds only one you know
one issue there's there's also things
like if you want to use texture
compression you know there is not a
standard their own high-performance one
to use on Android done there's also you
know there are there are also issues in
terms of how you should write your your
shaders and you know making sure that
you're really querying very carefully
also making sure that you do test those
shaders on a variety of GPUs because you
will see different performance cliffs
from device to device that being said
from a coding perspective you're
code is going to just is going to go
over the well you really have to look at
is audio because the audio standards are
very very different you're going to look
at touch and events which are very very
different networking actually if you're
not using SSL you can just use sockets
and secure socket code will come over
pretty much straight to be honest so
there's a lot you do get a lot even
actually you can actually use even
threading you can if you're using
standard pthreads you know as long as
you're not relying on making calls back
into the dalvik virtual machine you can
actually use those very easily or you
can easily tell you can actually tie
those back into dalvik threads and
there's actually a really nice library
than nvidia has provided for doing that
so there really are a lot of things you
can do and really one of the main
reasons we do the NDK is to allow people
to take advantage of tested code
sections that you you know code
libraries that you have written for
another platform so from that
perspective that plus the standard api's
do provide a really nice basis
especially for games you know we're can
s'more challenging because when you want
to take advantage of a lot of the
Android Android standard UI patterns you
know and those are you know there's a
lot of useful stuff in there even if it
comes to things like font rendering on
database storage isn't there so if you
want to use databases you're going to
have to make a call through Jay and I do
know we're going to get to make a call
through Jan that's right remember I the
Java interfaces in Android are very very
easy to use compared to c and c++
there's a lot fewer ways to shoot
yourself in the foot and you'll end up
writing a lot less code a good example
of this is when you're doing your
gameplay you know every large-scale see
puff puff project I've worked on has its
own resource management and reflection
system which of course is built-in to
dalvik and into the Java framework so
you can actually save yourself a lot of
time especially when you're dealing with
platform specific things but even even
when you're not by going to dalvik or
another virtual machine absolutely yeah
and there's plenty of places even in a
game where it makes a lot of sense to
take advantage of android framework it
resources things like notifications for
example you know networking it's just
nice to take advantage they have the
built-in HTTP stack
built in SSL implementation all that
kind of stuff so there is a bunch of
stuff that it does make sense to
actually move code over to the dalvik
virtual machine but that being said it's
you know for thing for your core code
especially things like physics engines
that that you know may be written
entirely in native code things like
box2d there's really no reason not to
just use that code as it is if it's a
well-tested bit of code absolutely okay
I think that's enough on that producer
rato are there any more questions ok
that's great well cells right on the
producer camp that is the hour or you're
getting the hang of that today that's
awesome job yeah we're running a little
low on time but something occurs to me
which is it we did not actually go in in
order of what people voted on that is
true we we sort of went in order of what
we personally thought was cool I
especially in order of these big
profitable games which I think makes us
look a lot like tools of the game
oligopoly establishment well you know
and i will say that that all of these
games uh you know really are fun like
these are they and their and they're
beautiful they might they mad we don't
want to be tools no that's true in
action i didn't i know i would have
added need for speed hot pursuit by the
way to this list had I been a tool
because I actually love Need for Speed
hoppers hot pursuit I have ever since it
came out it's a tool thing and and and I
did but I didn't I didn't nominate it
full list because there were so many
other big games on the list already well
so that zine point is we need to look at
tractor digger well it says subtractor
dinner is not actually a racing game I'm
gonna bring it up just very very quickly
voted number one was voted number one it
is built it is built using and engine
and it is by the way you know who else
is a tool anybody who watches this show
and doesn't vote for stuff so so this is
actually a puzzle game and your goal is
to move things into the tractor you've
got a dual joystick control and then we
can we can actually take this stuff and
and move it into the into this dumpster
here and it's actually pretty cool it is
not a racing game they didn't say race
again we said driving game it is sort it
sort of are you driving a tractor
yes I think you're driving a tractor so
I'm now for some reason I ganas snapping
fingers I because the reason why I don't
have a dist Ablett plugged in so let's
let's actually show you what i was doing
rather than have me just looking down
that's why we we look at the monitor
yeah exactly yeah that's what we have
yeah that's a good point so anyways oh
it's backwards though that's really hard
never mind he just glanced at it yeah
exactly yeah so say we can actually take
advantage of physics here to scoop up
the rock into our little tractor and
then we can actually flip it all the way
around to the other side in order to
dump it back into the dumpster but it is
a puzzle game and it's cool you're
driving a tractor and it's something I
haven't seen before it is an Anand
engine game which is always nice to see
if you haven't actually used engine to
end engine before it is a really nice 2d
game development platform written for
Android we actually have them showing
off the tools chain at Google i/o this
year and it really does look it looks
nice I and and they're doing a lot of
investment in it which is which is
exciting Oh whether you're not trying to
get the boulders into the into the into
the truck just just so I did a good job
of it there was you did you did know
you're at the controls I you know the
controls work well you know there's
definitely some parts of this game where
I want to see higher resolution artwork
you know cut some some some more work
done on some of the textures to the so
that it looks less this sort of
repeating pattern that you're seeing
there at the bottom it just it just
screams I'm tiling something right we're
going to do that by the way is to create
three or four random textures and just
randomize them for a texture like this
you can use there's actually some
photoshop plugins to do this yeah you
get something that has like four or five
different textures but they all tile
seamlessly along the edges and and then
you just pick them at random and yeah
actually looks really yeah it really
does and that same thing I would say
with the grass texture it's just like
tile tile tile tile tile it would I
would love to see a little bit of work
because there's so much work that
actually went into the vehicles in this
game yeah they're cool and you know what
I dig the background too even though
it's dead photo it's like out of focus
yes depth of field effect to it good job
there yeah adequately let's move on
let's move on again not not not not not
a racing game another
one that's that's in the category of
somewhat someone small someone smaller
games is a drag racing from Nitro nation
and it's good this game was was it is
kind of fun but it really just seemed to
be an exercise in in trying to end up
getting me to buy stuff which was a
little unfortunate you know it's like
what I found was that pretty much no
matter how well I did in the game if I
did not have a car that was that was
that was good enough and this was not an
example of that I was just going to lose
and mostly because just kind of minimal
controls here and I actually played this
game not particularly well I should
actually be I was gonna say shifting you
see you get a good shift if you shift
like a moron you're not going to get
anything yeah but even if you shift
really really well you know there's a
point in which your car just isn't good
enough and and you have to buy a new car
the only way to buy new cars to get
respect and it's very challenging to get
respect within the game without actually
paying money and I kind of so I kind of
wish the game had sort of a deeper grind
factor maybe it's there and I just
didn't see it in my playing of the game
that banks in the game plays well it
looks pretty good I'm a little tiny bit
blurry here on the size of a transformer
prime only a button matter yeah it's I
wouldn't say that it's a yeah yes yeah
when you behold a match alluvion it
shows yeah a little upshift thing and
then you press the button and it says
good job exactly yeah so so yeah so it's
pretty it's pretty limited but I wanted
to at least bring it up you know it's
and again if you like this kind of game
it seems to be a pretty good version of
that of an attorney to that genre I
really have it but not on tablet exactly
now another completely different kind of
rates racing game is reckless getaway
the great game this this is is super fun
um you know it's it's uh and it actually
has a cute little story behind behind it
that you are you know trying to get away
let's actually do it loosely recklessly
yeah and even little details like please
wait robbery in progress i love the
money flying
out of your car there's all sorts of
cool jumps you can take there is just
tons and tons and tons of stuff to do in
this game I would have loved to have a
little bit more control over and then
maybe that's just me because I you know
I'm old and I don't have the greatest
reflexes but I felt like this control
scheme was actually really difficult to
manage I I would have actually liked you
know some really sensitive tilt controls
which is odd because as you know i hate
tilt controls it driving games are one
of the few places in which i find that
tilt controls actually are not so bad
and i often prefer especially if they're
you know if they're reasonably sensitive
but but this game is really well done
and it's you know it's it's i love this
i love the perspective you know again we
took a jump there all the all the
background work they've done I mean this
is it's just it's a professional time I
mean there's no question about that
absolutely and so you know as I said I
was glad to see this up there this game
hasn't gotten a lot of love recently and
you know I think it's just I think it's
a really well done well done title that
does something substantially different
in this genre you know there's raw
there's you're like what I you know
three different kinds of games that we
see really commonly in the genre we see
sort of slot racing games which are over
the head where you see a large
percentage of the track we seen on more
traditional driving games and then this
is a this is a perspective we don't see
nearly as much which is kind of
reminiscent of the perspective from
expire you know the original overhead
mines Mia overhead racing overhead
racing game and it's awesome so you know
I I definitely you know here's by the
way an example of a developer who just
did not know what to do with the back
key here we are we've got two screens
such play again and continue and and you
know and they're like so what do we do
here with the back key actually in this
particular case play again or continue
there is actually a third option which
is which would be exit to the main menu
and not heading the back key actually
should eggs eggs at you back here
there's no reason why it needs to be
play and continue this is sort of a
design so they made the back you do
nothing that's bad should always do
something especially at the end of the
game when when you might just want to
want to exit and switch game modes and
insane right when have to target the
continue button which is really
unfortunate i remember the back button
to those two things and some
it moves you back to the previous
activity or it dismisses dialogues so if
you're saying to yourself wow what I'm
looking at here has no meaningful yeah
back thing ya know maybe it's because
you need to think of it more as a
dismissing rather than a movie yeah
continue continue actually does not when
I saw continued I didn't what does
continue me I had no idea and then I
realized what they what continued
actually does is take you back to the
selection screen so continues really not
doesn't really make much sense they're
certainly there are some places where we
stretch a little bit but you know what
suck it up android has a back button and
people expect to be able to use it so
here's i just wanted to bring up tiny
little racing oh yeah you know what we
were gonna look at this a while ago and
and then then we didn't so fresh often
said actually while we really loved this
and it turned out I was wrong mom it
turned out that actually was a different
game with a really really similar name
that we really really love but this
still a good game so let's talk about it
first of all we see this oh don't ever
do this don't ever do this because we at
least autofill come on oh well it's not
just that uh one is that I'm not using
the standard android keyboard oh yeah so
you know so like the question is I'm
going to stick this in the dock now um
and the keyboard doesn't work number 2
count you in go to switch the camera
turn to camera two breathe breathe no
that's no I right there right okay now
look look at what poor Dan is trying to
do here yeah ice I just quit the game
but I was trying to type my name and I
can't type on the keyboard he's just
amazingly frustrated with this whole
thing because because we're not using
one of the default input methods of
Android so I can't actually type my name
using the keyboard that's in front of me
so this is also so don't use your own
input method as a general rule even
though it looks really cool and you can
put Comic Sans on there which also i say
never use Comic Sans but that's a
different question yeah you just get the
vision so that's one thing this game is
this game is fun I want I definitely
want to see some higher resolution
graphics everything here is really
really blurry yeah this what this game
wasn't really built for a tablet now
also the models
are really low res so you get the you
get the feeling that maybe this was
tuned for a much less capable device and
that's fine um but what you might want
to do and this is just a general game
design idea um in general it's not very
difficult to make a model that's very
high polygon count and the hard part is
reducing it to a low Paul Young count
yeah so if you keep your sources and
just you know every now and then when
the state of Technology gets there put
some better models in your game actually
you know to be honest for me I actually
know the models i think the car models
are really good it's the rest of
everything else that that that that i
want to see you know the car models are
attractive of my point is they're low
pollock yeah and their end they all day
and they don't they don't really look
like anything else in the game you know
and i think it's cute there's some of
the design element but i would love to
see you know some some even if the
backgrounds are going to look like that
it'd be kind of cool if they were a
little bit soft focus that girl thing
now let's just move to camera two really
quick um you'll notice that my
excessively large hands you still have
to kind of reach it get the yeah sorry
we're we're losing hd9 here and right I
button there I mean there it really is a
stretch um yeah this is not this is an
example of buttons that are not scaled
based upon the pixel density of the
screen you know they're they're looking
at there there there's they're stretched
based upon the screen size and it's a
kind of thing so we have two options
here one is we can look at pixel density
that thought that helps a little bit the
other thing is we can actually have a
temper a separate tablet layout that
would help even more yeah remember that
android has some really nice features
for putting together layouts for
different screens and a lot of game
developers say well that's that doesn't
affect me at all because i'm not making
views and i'm not using exactly but you
know what you don't have to use that for
just views or dialogue designs or UI
designs what you can do is put constant
values in there and then pull those out
based on the resource ID and you'll get
the different values based on
which screen size you're on or you know
whatever you filtered on absolutely and
again you can you can you can do a
couple things one is you can actually
get the pixel density and you can just
imply that to what you're doing in
OpenGL so that you're actually getting
something that's the correct physical
size which is really important because
what you want to make sure it's also if
if if this screen you know we're very
very small you'd still want those things
to be very very large and in any of this
thing looks like it's just stretching
based on the size of the screen so
that's definitely one thing making it
automatic is really important to so yeah
one thing you can do actually in OpenGL
that's like really super cool is define
your UI in in meters we sounds stupid
but trust me don't ever do like I've
been on projects where people like oh
maybe we want a little bit more you know
precision or whatever let's use
decimeters or something exactly and it
just screws up your physics system does
every though but define your UI in
meters and then just have a matrix that
scales from meters to screen units and
you'll definitely detest this on a wide
variety of physical screen sizes but
it's it's much much easier than actually
trying to come up with you know lots and
lots of individual layouts to handle
every single set of that's every said
everything about combination and I'm not
going to lie to you this isn't easy
there is no simple thing yeah that you
can do especially if you're dealing with
different aspect ratios but it will be
worth it yeah I mean you know the key
thing you know you know if you're trying
to make the HUD look super attractive
and perfect it's definitely a bunch of
work oh yeah you know what your artists
you can do I'll show you exactly what
they're gonna say maybe like we have to
be pixel perfect yeah otherwise it's no
good um and that actually uh is I said I
would never swear on this show it is not
true very good as well I know I I heard
coming and I heard like you know there's
there there is there yeah exactly let me
tell you why it's not true so that was
extremely true back when we were working
with ntsc TVs or 480p or even you know a
really high resolution on a big screen
but today everything is by letting your
filtered at least well not only that
yeah
so we're talking about these really
really dense displays now okay fine if
you're supporting some random old thing
that has a very low density display yeah
you might want to think about both
really here's here's an example let's
take a look at Nexus 7 Nexus 7 can't
tell at Nexus 7 all the icons you see
here for every single app are actually
being scaled down we did not actually
come up with new icons for every single
app at this pixel density right you know
this is a 213 DPI and we scaled from
what 250 years or 220 yeah at some end
to 245 or tea yeah and and so we're
scaling down a purse are a small
fraction honestly on this high of a
density pixel density to display you
don't even notice it most of the time
you can't actually go and create icons
at at 213 DPI you want to but we looked
at it we said it's just not worth it and
so I think that I think that says a lot
about scaling down if you're you know
even even and again icons are the worst
thing you can scale typically because
they're really really information dense
except for text but even I got a lot of
icons contain text and a lot of icons
contain line art and details that needy
you would normally think oh this
shouldn't scale don't reality yeah the
reality is that and actually take one
left less look at the tablet I want to
look with the icon today five minutes
overtime and producer rato is like
packing up his stuff ready to go so just
just one thing out of all these icons
there are two icons that actually I
think are reasonable Android icons that
is the tractor digger icon believe it or
not in the GTA icon yeah every single
one at all just like it's been maybe
lifted from somebody else's yeah yeah
come on guys it's let's let's let's
let's try to make things every one of
those looks the same it's hard to
actually differentiate the content of
all those other ones but tracker digger
and GT are really really easy to
differentiate it's going to say mmm
asphalt 7 the game left icon looks like
a six it looks like acid 76 I'm just
saying alright alright so that's it next
so yeah everyone make sure to vote next
week that's what I got so uh next week's
apps are sports because it's the
Olympics exactly we'll have been the
Olympics yes so we really good sports
games next week now if if you don't know
how this works you go to our page
at developers.google.com /live not which
is not down in the corner because this
is the wrong title but it will be or you
know the link will always be in the
event that we put on on our Google+ page
at that link developer android com / +
um go there and there is at the very
bottom scroll down to the bottom don't
you know ignore the big black video
thing that doesn't have anything in it
because there is no video yet ignore
that scroll down scroll down further
then at the bottom of the page there's a
moderator link it's actually not like
it's actually embedded because the
people that did it are like really cool
web people mm-hmm um it's embedded in
the page and you can suggest new apps or
games you can flip to the tablet if you
want to see what this you really like it
what this looked at yeah so I put this
up here on on our tablet you can
actually go you can see our everything
we've looked at you can see we now are
looking at sports games for next time
and right now we are how we already have
our our first suggestion some of which
don't look like sports games so high
when do you plan to review puzzle game
not week so do that somewhere else yeah
this will be marked as inappropriate
let's flag that is inappropriate but
thanks guys we love puzzle games at some
point it'll happen to stay tuned just
keep watching the show exactly exactly
so stay tuned can you don't watch the
show every week how are you going to
know right exactly so to definitely
continue to nominate continue to vote
you know we're really excited about a
lot of what we saw this week and I'm
looking forward to seeing some great
sports games and your Golf is a sport so
you want to just as an example summer
but but we're thinking about things I
want I want most you know things that
are a lot of Olympic sports too is if
there's something good that we've missed
it doesn't have to be summer big heroes
a great dressage op out there I want to
see it but the other thing that I want
to remind you is we our goal here is to
help developers make better games so we
may not always review the most pop
games not we may not always be kind to
some games but our goal is to at least
help you understand how a game could be
better now sometimes uh we don't
accomplish that because the game is so
great to begin with radiant defense but
in general besides if we're critical a
game is because we think it's it's
decent but could be better and for that
reason actually our colleague rato has
renamed his show the Friday app clinic
hmm I we may do something similar I
don't know leaves a comment on our G+
page yeah let it let us know exactly
okay we got to get out of here where
they over time yeah we started late
though so it's you know it's we can be a
little over yeah so thanks once again to
our producer Rick homebuyer our engineer
Daniel Pham and we will see you next
week cheers